the ideas of President Donald Trump
increasingly indistinguishable from
those of conspiracy theorists Alex Jones
of Infowars Fame yesterday President
Trump was speaking to US Central Command
he made a we could call it a departure
we could call it a slight detour
probably both understatements a
departure from his prepared remarks and
made the stunning claim that media is
intentionally covering up or not
reporting on terrorist attacks
I couldn't possibly dream of saying
something better or more eloquently than
our president so I will show you what it
was that he said yesterday you've seen
what happened in Paris and nice all over
Europe it's happening it's gotten to a
point where it's not even being reported
and in many cases the very very
dishonest press doesn't want to report
it hmm they have their reasons and you
understand that there's absolutely no
evidence to suggest that this is true
that the press doesn't want to report it
this is sort of playing on the comments
from adviser Kellyanne Conway on MSNBC
last week which we discussed yesterday
where she just made up the existence of
something called the bowling-green
Massacre to justify the muslim-majority
country immigration ban this happens to
be straight out of the Infowars alex
jones playbook which apparently trump
doesn't consider to be fake news here's
a sampling of headlines from Alex
Jones's Infowars fake news mainstream
media whitewashes Islamic terror in
Berlin propagandist desperate to hide
the obvious on July 29th scandal mass
media covers up terrorism to protect
Islam June 24 June he covering up terror
plots to protect Muslim migrants July 24
media caught covering up Islamic ties in
Munich attack and of course July 25th
video terror in Germany the truth they
hide mass media deception to conceal
what's really happening the truth is not
surprisingly the opposite of what Donald
Trump is saying not every terrorist
attack
gets broad national or international
coverage but to suggest that there is an
effort not to report on terror is absurd
in fact corporate media does the
opposite corporate media does
wall-to-wall coverage of terror if
you're going to argue anything about
corporate media just media's coverage of
terror it's that they cover it so much
Pat that people end up thinking the
world is way more dangerous than it
really is in other words people think
that it's much more likely that they
would be the victims of a terror attack
than it is in reality because of media
coverage well it's interesting because
usually when we talk about conspiracy
theories we talk about people on the
outside claiming there's a big
government cover-up then the government
has the secret story behind 9/11 or the
moon landing or if they're making the
frogs gay or not right sure Trump is on
the inside now so you think you would
know and what is true is that there's
disproportionate coverage of terror
attacks committed by Muslims versus
regular old white dudes and I've told
you many times the undeniable statistics
that most terror in the world is
conducted by Muslims most terror in the
United States is conducted by just
American white men interestingly this
story not not from the US but from
Canada Donald Trump ignored the mass
shooting that occurred at a mosque in
Quebec last week which killed six
Muslims conducted by a trump supporting
sort of alt-right anti-feminist dude but
immediately Donald Trump tweeted about
an attack at the Louvre museum in Paris
where nobody was killed at all there was
a recent study conducted which concluded
that a person in America is seven times
more likely to be killed by a white
nationalist than an Islamic extremist
and here's where it gets really
interesting right after Donald Trump's
speech our buddy
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
told reporters hey we're going to put
out a list of these attacks that we
don't believe are getting enough
coverage or any coverage and later in
the day the White House published a list
of attacks that they say we're either
executed or inspired by Isis the Islamic
state it's a very long list
I'll just put up part of the list for
you here and you'll notice that many of
these attacks were
covered extensively Paris and January of
2015 nice and February of 2015 I mean
you look at this list the Guardian did a
rebuttal where they said hey we actually
covered every single one of these but
what this really gets to is a sort of
amorphous idea of number one what is
enough coverage and number two who gets
to decide if it's enough coverage and
fundamentally the idea Pat that the
president's administration decides what
is the right or correct amount of
coverage of a particular incident it's
part of this authoritarian anti-media
anti free speech thing that is becoming
the calling card of the Trump
administration and the troubling thing
here too is that Alex Jones claims that
Infowars might be getting White House
press credentials yes indeed which would
validate them just as much as CNN and
ABC and the rest of them arguably more
in the eyes of Trump because Trump has
called CNN fake news but right my
knowledge he's not called Infowars or
Breitbart fake news and it seems like
he's increasingly deferring to them if
you are looking at this from a sane and
rational perspective you say Oh any
idiot can realize that number one Trump
is not the authority on what is and
isn't over or under covered by media and
number two nobody's gonna fall for this
nobody's going to believe this but this
is actually much more dangerous than a
rational and clear thinking individual
might imagine it's a distraction it's
fake news from Trump but it's super
dangerous because Trump has now set up
Trump ian's to believe that even if
there are not reports of attacks that
attacks are going on news of which is
being suppressed by fake news liberal
media if you believe the Trump narrative
that's why did this is so dangerous Pat
it's very easy to say Trump's obvious
lies aren't really a big deal
and maybe in and of themselves they're
not a big deal he's lying he's a liar
he's constantly lying fine but millions
of people believe this stuff and now he
it's in a way it's evil genius and
sometimes I think that the guy is doing
this stuff on purpose sometimes I think
he's stumbling
across this stuff sheerly because of
merely because of his sheer idiocy but
now he's set it up so that even if
trumpets don't hear about terror attacks
some percentage of them will believe the
terror is happening they're just not
hearing about it from media because
there's a cover-up and I think you can
kind of tell the difference too
sometimes he'll say things that are
dishonest and you buy the look on his
face you could tell he doesn't actually
believe this but he knows that maybe a
quarter of Americans support him and
will just believe him no matter what yes
and they will and it's having an impact
and that's why this is so very dangerous
in a world I don't know what the right
term is a post factual world there's the
different buzzwords that are floating
around what I can tell you is that the
power of trumps lies comes not from
Trump himself but from the fact that so
many trumpets believe what he says no
matter what it is